[музика]
так ліцеїсти військового ліцею імені
Івана Богуна відпрацьовують дії солдата
в бою одна команда займає оборону інша
йдем на наступ
це командна військово-тактична гра у ній
треба вразити противника безпечним
лазерним променем працюючи у групах юній
Захисники розвивають швидкість мислення
і розробляють тактику бою цими та іншими
вправами у Київському військовому ліцеї
імені Івана Богуна виховують майбутніх
офіцерів літо збройних сил України із
чотирьох основних складових чотирьох
англомовний Бандери з майстер спорту
золотої медалі оце де бандеровець щирий
патріот то вже це ворог потім ідеологія
Україна повинсе і потім ідуть по
складовим іде моральна підготовка тобто
я воїн я був боротись я переможець я
бавовнявець я коза-характерник і
слідуючий для психологічна долати
труднощі замість цивільного життя юнаки
і дівчата віком від 13 до 17 років
обрали однострій та військовий режим тут
їх готують до вступу у вищі навчальні
заклади дають азитупографії домедичної
підготовки вчать долати воду і висоту
вчать стрільбі і тактиці бою а серед
викладачів є діючі військовослужбовці
які пройшли АТО і зараз беруть участь у
бойових діях та діляться з підлітками
своїм бойовим досвідом Чим цікавий
бойовий досвід саме для дітей насамперед
тим що це є вже нова жива війна Яка
відрізняється абсолютно від усього
навіть Той досвід 14-15 16-го 17-го
років він абсолютно не може порівнятися
із повномасштабним вторгненням тому що
це є зовсім інша війна тобто змінюється
тактика вводиться нові підрозділи
з'являється нові посади як БПЛА вони
починають розуміти що можна як зробити
щоб краще долучити доведення там можливо
двоспальних оборонних дій що не варто
долучати і з цією практикою і з
практикою попередніх він вони починають
асимілювати ці всі знання і потім
знаходити своє рішення тому що в
подальшому майбутнє командири від
їхнього рішення залежить хід бою Тут
щодня муштрують майбутніх офіцерів
уроками спортивними заняттями і
військовою підготовкою
раз два раз два раз два понад 7 тисяч
випускників ліцею зараз боронять Україну
а серед теперішніх ліцеїстів чимало тих
хто походить з військових династій
ізмалку мріє встати офіцером бажання
було що змалечку в мене батьки військові
тож це якби можна сказати династія
виховали таке почуття відповідальності
для мене військовий це приклад це
показник
сказати правильно
показник статусу держави показники рівня
і розвитку Андрій у 16 цього року він
закінчує військовий ліцей і планує
вступати до військової академії в Одесі
на факультет підготовки спеціалістів
керування силами десантно-штурмових
військ і незважаючи на те що в країні
йде повномасштабна війна він твердо
переконаний що ухвалив правильне рішення
що я боявся попасти на лінію фронту і з
цією побоювання таких не було
звісно є певні страхи перед смертю перед
зіткненням але хто не боїться той дурень
кожен батько кожна мати переживає за
свого сина за свою доньку
але краще я піду ти підготовлені ніж
мене мобілізують Я нічого не буду знати
Та майже всі богунівці повернулися до
навчання каже начальник ліцею А на місце
тих хто не повернувся знайшлося чимало
охочих ми тільки за професійну розбили
по офіцер Ніяк не може бути примусово і
чим більше нас буде не тільки по
кількості і за рівнем мотивації
підготовки і по забезпеченню то і буде
швидше перемога і тут не просто ж
одноразова бо ми не знаємо як буде через
місяць через два там ну Ми віримо і
працюємо на перемогу і якщо Минулого
року кількість вступників трохи
зменшилася то вже цього року їх знову
побільшало мінімум дві людини на місце а
серед дівчат по 5-6 ми на всі вакансії
до набрали без проблем то есть всі які
були в ваканті там 3-5 потім шість всі
набрали і зараз у нас тут ми не
переживаємо якщо навіть десь якісь там у
нас в нас завжди мінімум 5-8 чоловік в
резерві тобто якщо хто втратив мотивацію
Ми кажемо
добре що зараз бо нам найгірше коли на
передові розумієте тут ще тут ще Вибір є
тут і в нас є резерв то ми сильно ми
тільки Ну за ми ж за професійного
офіцери тільки за окликом серця за
власником жодного примусового це
немосковія що має бути Штрафбат і
заграннат потрапити у ліцей не так легко
треба здати іспит з української
англійської історії та фізичної
підготовки А у своїх есе під час вступу
підлітки пишуть Чому вони мріють бути
військовими і цьогорічна їхні твори
вплинула повномасштабна війна що мріє
бути пілотом льотчиком приводом Києва
все там морські
котиком там в десантником все танкістом
ну пише а нехай маси малюють гайси як
вони це так то що допомогли це є ППО
арістєди Петрів зараз вже почали
леопарди писати Де це ми боролися ліфани
Це ці вже нові вступники так так вони
фанати вони фанати то есть Як ви
зрозуміли що в них ще пока романтиз
романтика і миролики драйвером цей але
нам головне щоб батьки їх благословили
щоб дали їм зелене світло зараз у ліцеї
навчається
750 богунівців серед них 8% дівчат по
дві у кожному взводі Євгенія мріяла
вступити сюди ще 7 класу відколи
дізналася про перший набір дівчат ще з 7
класу вперше колеги дізналася про перший
набір дівчат я задумалася і
хотіла спробувати і якось так з роками і
я зрозуміла в дев'ятому класі що це
точно моє бажання що я хочу бути
захисницею своєї країни і
так йшла йшла йшла до своєї мети ліцеїст
для мене це
вихована сильна з великою силою волі
людина яка уже знає що вона прагне в
житті вона вже знає ким вона хоче бути і
це є патріот який любить свою
Батьківщину і готову віддати своє життя
за Україну з початком повномасштабного
вторгнення батьки і друзі Євгенії
просили її змінити своє дослідження
проте майбутнє офіцерка наполягла на
своєму звичайно просила зробити якісь
інший вибір передумати але я сказала що
це моє життя і ви маєте поважати те що я
обираю відповідно вони погодилися і
сказали Так справді Це твоя майбутня
доля і ти думаєш робити те що тобі
подобається і на цьому Ми з ними
завершили тему вони мене підтримують і
до сьогоднішнього дня я людина яка
ставить собі мету і ідея своїми кроками
по ній тому з початку війни нічого
особливого не змінилося Але були трохи
страхи якийсь думки і друзі які цивільні
говорили про те щоб я думала але що
думаєте якщо я вже точно знаю ким хочу
бути і точно знаю що
я хочу бути в формі та ходити у погонах
у ліцеї перекону їхнім учням не потрібно
йти воювати у найближчі роки адже вони
лише на початку свого військового шляху
а залучати до бойових дій можуть лише
курсантів старших курсів військових
вишів як це було на початку 2022 року із
курсантами у Києві та Харкові які
допомагали відбивати атаки ворога не
проживайте їм в атаку не треба не завтра
не післязав не через місяць і навіть
через рік Навіть через рік в кращому
випадку кращому випадку це можливо через
2,5 роки де вони будуть охороняти
містечко якусь базу то есть то ще бо
треба не менше 2 роки це базова
підготовка потім на третьому починається
спеціалізація спеціальна і можливо як
було коли найважче то залучали третій
третій четвертий тут для посилення да
4-5 Має бути готовий до дострокової
завжди має бути завжди це якби прописано
в документах зараз батьки більшості
ліцеїстів знаходяться на передовій чи
волонтерять у 23 дітей батьки загинули
під час бойових дій тому викладачі ліцею
імені Богуна стають для них і
психологами і родиною дуже складно тому
що в нас кожна дитина зі своєї історії в
зв'язку з тим що війна є діти в котрих
прямо зараз або вчора або завтра десь
помирає батько на фронті в когось брат в
полоні в кого ще якісь певні життєві
обставини хтось проходить після окупації
Тобто це складні Життєві історії котрі
Вони переживають прямо у нас на очах
випускники наші от дуже багато їх зараз
на передові ті які мають найменше
можливості от відпускають їх на шість
днів на три дні на 10 вони всі
проїжджають через ліцей І це так приємно
тому що вони всі біжать до своїх
вчителів до своїх офіцерів
розповідаю щось радяться до цього часу
багато хто пише це не тільки привітання
якісь там з днем народження З Новим
роком Це просто от написати я є Я живу а
деякі Захисники повертаються в ліцей щоб
самим стати наставниками для молоді як
наприклад Андрій Який вже пройшов в
службу в осу в Пісках а потім в
Маріуполі в мій час коли я тут навчався
особисто і взагалі у часи до війни нас
вчили так як зараз на щастя вчать росіян
бути квадратними виконувати команди і не
приймати самостійне рішення без команди
зверху Особисто я прихильник цієї думки
що потрібно зараз в сучасній армії
виховувати майбутніх командирів
майбутніх офіцерів в креативному
напрямку тому що в той час коли чекаєш
команду зверху В тебе немає ні зв'язку
немає як зв'язатися з вищим
командуванням і ти Чекаєш Чекаєш ти
просто втрачаєш життя своїх підлеглих
потрібно бути креативним і вміти
правильно прийняти рішення для того аби
зберегти життя Я навчаю тому щоб мої
випускники в подальшому будечого
офіцерами в першу чергу дивилися на
життя підлеглого особового складу і
вміли креативно приймати рішення це
правильно для того аби зберегти більше
життів майже 90% ліцеїстів потім
вступають у військові вищі і стають
офіцерами у сухопутних читанкових
військах дешеве розвідці чи силах
спецоперацій це свідомий вибір кожного з
них бо не вмотивованих учнів
відраховують моє головне завдання
Вселити в них Віру впевненість перемозі
що вони стали фанатами фанатами Ну як як
мені прищепили колись тоді якщо навіть
так трапиться що хтось не вступить Це
точно будуть патріотично налаштовані
діти серед них точно не буде лаборантів
це 100%. тому що в них зовсім-зовсім
інший за два роки вони тут стають
дорослими патріотично налаштованими і ці
точно люблять свою державу А ті
богунівці які вирішили пов’язати своє
життя зі збройними силами України
прагнуть стати майбутньою військовою
елітою Я думаю що перемога буде дуже
швидко і вона точно буде ми всі українці
в це віримо прагне мо всіма силами
допомагаємо цьому А наші збройні сили
вже розвиваються і я впевнена що
НАТО нам в цьому ще більше Допоможе і
взагалі для України як кожна українець
вважає велике майбутнє